one of the things that's come up in
discussions about friends over the years
is uh learning lines is not kind of like
theater yeah but you don't you're not
that keen on learning lines oh you're
right
you get to do it again if you don't know
your lines but yes i
i didn't always have an easy time
remembering my lines on friends so you
would not well i suppose cheat is it
cheated kind of yeah yeah so where would
you put your lines well okay so the
writers would sometimes give you new
scripts
right on the spot or right before and
sometimes i also didn't prepare as much
as i should have so
i would um like put the uh my lines
either in the fruit bowl sometimes
sometimes in the sink i'll just be
sitting there and then you'd go to the
sink and pretend to wash and
look a couple of pages in
and um yeah one time in particular i had
something large to say it was like a i
would call it like a paragraph and i
wear like a
two-incher um
that sounds weird uh anyway
yes and matt leblanc
didn't tell me obviously it was a prank
on me and he took my i didn't know it at
all and he took the piece of paper that
i had in the fruit bowl and i was like
getting an apple
and i just i i don't you say wang it
winged it whatever the word is i did and
i think it worked out but it was not
okay
but did he confess yeah on the friends
reunion well not until then that's when
i learned it
wow that's a long time to keep that
secret yeah yeah
[Music]